mario jean en pleine pandémie vous avez
recommencé à donner des spectacles à
piedmont théâtre des pays d'en haut
les spectateurs sont séparés avec des
vitres de plexiglas comment ça se passe
c'est pas naturel mais ça se passe
drôlement gay parce que je pense que les
gens sont tellement heureux de sortir de
voir un show de participer à quelque
chose et moins jeunes aux je suis
tellement content de le retrouver sur
scène d'avoir du monde et ça que cette
chimie la part facilement malgré les
malgré les masques malgré le purell à
l'entrée malgré des pyrénées que parce
que votre sixième spectacle s'intitule
aller de l'avant par un an que vous
traînez avec moins aller de l'avant tant
de panneaux mis cinq ans pour fournir de
la part des miens j'ai essayé de faire
et que je pense j'en avais 10
pagesjaunes abandonné de jokela dessus
ok j'en ai pris quelques unes dans le
show que je quand j'ai commencé à faire
le show ça n'a pas été long que je me
suis rendu compte que j'ai pas besoin
d'être solide déjà ils veulent pas avant
quelques quelques brides sont instruits
et 1 et les fans en plein dans place
l'on veut en parler là mais on entend
ses tentures parce que les gens je pense
qu'ils sont à lire ce sont tannés de
vouloir de penser à ça d'avoir leur
opinion d'eux alors tout le truc du
virus sur le gâteau en août on peut
oublier ce pour une soirée je pense que
déjà le message qui m'envoyait de par
leurs réactions
c'était ça parlons toujours de la
pandémie dans votre nouveau spectacle
vous parlez de vos enfants mais aussi de
consentement sexuel
oui a raconté qu'on vient de passer
c'est l'actualité kg 4 la part des mis à
frapper ça a été la presse ça ça roulait
tout ça je revisite est un peu mon
spectacle pour savoir si tout est encore
actuel tête encore puis le numéro sur la
consentement sexuel mais je l'avais fait
l'année passée et puis tu sais ça rien
que je t'aurais droit et c'est peut-être
que ça savoir poser un peu d'actualité
ben non c'est venu est le message est
encore à d'à propos de ce que je dis qui
malade dablé je m'adresse au goûter si
c'est ma blonde qui me donne un peu cet
angle-là adéquat on peut dire ce qu'on
veut sur le consentement sexuel mais
quand vous vous parler entre eux de go
je pense que c'est là que ça parle le
plus le message quand moi je dis quelque
chose mais le cheminot 2 mondial
cependant ça marche lui peut-être des
coups de plus que si ça passait dans les
médias ou ailleurs un message de sid
vous avez fait prendre conscience que
coûte une femme quand ça disent non
c'est non et puis c'est pas plus grave
que ça c'est c'est non puis on passe à
autre chose et c'est une seule roue du
message est que si vous faites le
[Musique]
mais je pense fondamentalement de tout
ça c'est qu'il faut changer l'image
qu'on a de la sexualité
moi je l'échangé de pilote depuis
longtemps de ça fait 30 ans 35 ans
quitte avec ma blonde alors je sais un
peu que nommer mes fantasmes de 7,3 fait
longtemps que j'ai compris que ce n'est
pas demain que machete
mais ce trek mais c'est sûr que pour les
iphone oui parce que moi je dis tout à
ma blonde quand j'étais jeune j'allais
faire écoute des pipes des mains pour
réussir à tour un playboy prouver page
puis de voir une fille tenu à stara toi
cliquetant no 4 avec un autre ces
créatures
c'est ça l'image qu'ils ont c'est là
peut-être le problème que les gogues
pense et certaines fait aussi pensent
que la sexualité c'est ça et c'est pour
cela que c'est peut-être à ce niveau là
qu'il faut jouer auprès des jeunes
changer cette perception on a tout vu
mais spectacle total et voyait toutefois
capable mais pas des voiries sinon quand
j'allais chicoutimi où tout donné dans
le milieu du mot vous avez la réputation
du bon gars de chez continûment messadi
gentillesse vous a parfois justement
jouer ni mauvais taux pas tight bataille
des fois je me suis rendu compte que des
quintés plus exigeant plus j'ai dit plus
tard notre plus maintenant plus
exigeants sur soi plus et quand tu es
bon gars tu reçois mais sans plus ça des
fois je m'en suis rendu compte mais je
m'en fous comme dans la 40 parce que je
suis incapable je suis incapable d'être
une star
est au dessus des petits jeux pas bamada
attaque moi je veux dormir la nuit
alors quand je me couche puis je me dis
j dc bon bagage une belle journée parce
qu'on a eu du fun avec notamment la
crainte est tellement aimé un tellement
apprécié moins bien est ce que ça
m'aurait donné plus de faire autre chose
peut-être mais c'est encore là pour moi
c'est dans ma nature tout simplement et
je suis heureux qu on se marie aux gens
ça a été un très beau 5 remercie de
coupe merci à vous merci bien mais je
peux maintenant mars à la vie normale à
la moi et je mets un moment annoncé
cette chanson on a trouvé aujourd'hui on
a rarement fait avec trenet ya là
dernier il y avait chaud y avait